gigi hadid addresses the rumors will she  and Kendall Jenner be taking over as  co-hosts on America's Next Top Model of  the show after 22 cycles with Tyra Banks  the modeling competition show is jumping  over to vh1 and needs a new host rumors  have been swirling that supermodel BFFs  kendall Jenner and Gigi Hadid are in the  running for the big gig ET was with the  20 year old on Sunday where she was coy  but optimistic about the opportunity I  fan of the show it's not it's not in  talks but never be willing to do a show  like yep while Gigi and Kendall would be  a fantastic combo we can't help but  think her younger sister Bella would be  a great co-host to the 19 year old was  honored as model of the year at the  Fashion Los Angeles Awards where Gigi  completely gushed over her baby sis and  her strong work ethic I'm so proud of  her she's such an incredible person and  hard worker she's just such a sweetheart  she's such a real and great person to be  around